Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricard Lobs.
And today I'm joined by Doctor Kaylyn o'connor. She
is professor in the Department of Logic and Philosophy of
Science at the University of California Herrin. She is
a philosopher of biology and be sciences, philosopher of
science and evolutionary game theorist. She is the author
of books like the Origins of Unfairness Games in the
Philosophy of Biology and the misinformation Age. And today
we're going to talk about some of her uh topics
. So some of the subjects she focus on.
So Doctor o'conner, welcome to the show. It's
a big pleasure to everyone. Oh, thanks for
having me, Ricardo. So let me start by
asking you since you apply a game theory in your
work or at least to some of your work.
So what is it basically? And to what kinds
of topics do you apply it? Uh Mostly.
Yeah. So game theory, it's um it's a
branch of math that is used to study strategic human
interactions. And so a strategic interaction. Is it
anything where you have two individuals who are interacting and
where they both care about what the other one does
. So I have some stake in the game and
what you're doing and the reverse is true. Um
Game theory when it was first developed was applied just
to humans. And usually the idea was we'll analyze
people as if they're fully rational and then use that
to predict what they might do or explain what we
see people doing. So assume that I think really
hard about what you're gonna do and then make my
best choice for an action based on what you're gonna
do and what I want to happen. Um Later
on, it was introduced to biology as well to
apply to different kinds of critters, you know,
to animals, even things like micro organisms sometimes,
and some of the assumptions were changed to think less
about like rationality and more about how um how animals
might learn to behave strategically or they might evolve to
behave strategically. So a lot of the work I
do uses those latter kinds of models or tools and
I've applied game theoretic models to all sorts of systems
. So I've used them to think about signaling in
biology and in humans. So things like human language
and how animals communicate with each other. I've used
them to think about like perception in the brain.
I've used them to think about things related to unfairness
, which is related to that book. You mentioned
like how to unfair norms emerge in human societies.
Um I've used them to think about the evolution of
moral emotions, like guilt and shame. Uh,
and also to some degree to think about stuff like
misinformation and the spread of knowledge and belief in humans
. Mhm. Yeah. And we'll get into some
of those topics, uh, later in our conversation
. But I would like to ask you now about
science, the institution of science and scientists themselves because
there's, that's also a topic that you study.
So are scientists themselves subject to social pressures? Uh
Yeah. OK. We're like jumping to different stuff
. So, yes, they are. This isn't
um an observation that's like new to me by any
means. It's something that people have been noticing and
talking about for decades and decades in thinking about how
science works. Uh So scientists of course, are
humans, they like other humans care about what other
people think they grew up in human societies. They
have human biases, human social tendencies. And there's
a lot of really compelling evidence showing that all of
that influences how science as an enterprise gets done.
Uh And I mean, one of the things that
uh we as humans are, at least to some
extent is we are conformist. So is conformity,
something that also happens in science and if so,
is it good or bad? Yeah. So this
is something that I've worked on with um a collaborator
of mine, Jim Weall. So the idea of
conformity of some sort mattering to science goes back a
pretty long way. So for example, Thomas Coon
, in this very famous book, The Structure of
Scientific Revolutions has this idea that, you know,
scientists tend to work within a paradigm and they'll all
be kind of attached to this para this way of
thinking about the world and there will be social pressure
sort of keeping people within the paradigm and supporting it
. And I think there's some idea there about people
conforming with each other. And then he has this
idea that like you get younger people who are less
part of this community coming up and challenging the old
notions in our work. What um Jim and I
did was thought about groups of learners who are getting
evidence from the world. So we built these models
of individuals who can gather evidence and share evidence.
And we asked, would they get better or worse
at learning if we made them want to conform?
And the way we included conformity in the model is
we assumed all the agents are in a network.
So this is something that represents their social connections.
Each node in the network is an individual and then
each link between them is like a social tie.
And so our agents um in deciding what evidence to
gather and what actions to take, they would both
take evidence that they had gathered or seen in the
past, but they would also think about what their
neighbors were doing. So, for example, if
I had a lot of evidence that say the COVID
vaccine is relatively low risk, but I had a
lot of neighbors who were not getting vaccinated. In
this model, I might choose not to get vaccinated
because I prefer to conform with neighbors. And then
we ask, how does that impact learning and decision
making in the group? And then these models,
we found that on average conformity would tend to make
the group worse at learning and individuals more likely to
take bad actions. And there were a couple of
reasons for that. So one thing is that conformity
would stop individuals from sharing good evidence. So say
, I think personally that vaccines are safe and I
have good evidence that that's the case. But I'm
with a bunch of people who aren't getting vaccinated if
I conform to them, I never tell them about
my good evidence. I never get vaccinated and let
them see what happens. So you create these kind
of information bottlenecks where good information isn't flowing in the
network, but the science or uh the science tend
to be a conservative enterprise. And if so,
what does that mean exactly within the domain of science
to be conservative? Yeah, that's a really um
a big question and I think a really hard one
to answer. So some people in philosophy of science
worry about conservatism in science and when they talk about
that. So this isn't, this is something I've
written a little bit on, but it's not like
a central topic for me. So just keep that
in mind when they talk about that. Um Usually
what they mean is something like there are forces or
structures in science that keep scientists working on the same
kinds of problems or keep them from, for example
, looking at questions that are too weird or too
outside the norm or that are, for example,
high risk, high reward or that are sometimes people
call it mavericky or um just more unusual. And
so a lot of people argue that there are forces
that kind of keep scientists from doing stuff that's too
different or too unusual. And sometimes people argue that
that's a bad thing that um what you want across
a community of science is to have at least a
good handful of people working on topics that maybe don't
seem right or hypotheses that people don't currently believe or
things that seem risky or strange. And if you
have that handful of people, maybe most of them
fail, but some of them do succeed. And
in doing so might discover things that are really unusual
or sort of revolutionize a science. So that's why
a lot of people are like, conservatism could be
bad in science. Um The different arguments I've heard
about like why you see conservatism in science are things
like uh well, increasingly the age of scientific investigators
is going up, increasingly it takes longer and longer
to get to the position where you're the head of
a lab and you might just be indoctrinated for a
very long time within a field before you're the one
picking the research choices. Um People argue that uh
grant giving agencies are inherently conservative because they're trying to
get these good outcomes. And so they tend to
give money to, to projects that look more safe
, more dependable, more reliable. Um Some agencies
have set up these sort of high risk, high
reward special grants to try to push against that.
I wrote this one paper that modeled scientific communities and
asked, OK, what would be the conditions under
which we'd expect conservative science to spread as people train
their students and then those students get jobs. And
the argument I made in that paper is that while
conservative science tends to be more like less risky,
you know, that you're gonna be able to get
some discovery and publish it compared to something that's more
high risk where maybe you're gonna get a huge payoff
, but maybe it's just not gonna turn out to
be anything interesting at all. Um And so in
my models, I made that assumption and I found
that often, in fact, high risk science would
be likely to spread because the people doing it are
getting these really high payoffs. They become, who
succeed, are getting these really high payoffs, they
become famous, their students can get jobs. But
the problem with that is that it's often hard to
repeat. So on the assumption that if I'm a
sort of risk taking scientist and I happen to be
successful, my students, if they try to take
risks, may or may not be, I find
that in those cases, conservatism can kind of dominate
in science. And I imagine that in this case
, it's high risk because it might imply several different
sorts of potential damage, like reputation damage and in
the extreme, perhaps losing one's own uh career and
academic credibility. I guess there can be those kinds
of risks and there can also just be the risk
that you spend a lot of time and effort on
some project and then you just don't get anything out
at the end. So for example, if you
think about someone who's trying to get tenure in an
academic system, they have to publish before the tenure
clock runs out. So if you take on a
project that like maybe it's gonna turn out great,
but there's a pretty good chance the whole project is
gonna fail, you can see why that might be
a bad choice for that individual. But these are
not easy problem. Uh These, these problems are
not easy to navigate, right? Because on the
one hand, it's understandable that uh looking at the
whole system, uh many times it's not worth it
to waste resources on research or ideas that won't produce
anything. Of course, I, I imagine that
it's hard before and to really know for sure what
would be wasteful or not. Uh, but on
the other hand, uh, we also very much
need, at least sometimes, uh, people who
think a little bit more outside of the box to
push the fields forward. Right. Yeah, that's
right. And I think, you know, say
you're the National Science Foundation in the US or say
you're, um, an eu grant giving body,
you're giving these grants, you are paid by tax
dollars and run through a government. And so you
need to justify to the people of, you know
, your country or your institution, why you're giving
the grants you're giving and what they're for. And
sometimes I think it can be really hard to say
like there was a good reason why we gave a
grant to this person who's doing this thing that sounds
kind of wacky or out there. Um And so
that I think there are like these very practical reasons
why you wouldn't necessarily want to support higher risk science
, even if you can make the argument like,
ok, but across a whole body of scientists,
we want to have at least some people doing this
higher risk stuff. Uh One of my colleagues,
Kyle Stanford has argued that um you know, changes
in funding, like have promoted conservatism in part because
when you had a good number of like independently wealthy
scientists, they could just do whatever they wanted,
right? Like they, you know, they didn't
have to answer to anybody if they think, like
, well, tomorrow I'm gonna go look at all
the earthworms all over England. Like Charles Darwin did
. Who's gonna say no? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. That, that was exactly one of the
things that was coming to my mind while you were
speaking because, uh, I mean, of course
, historically, we know that most of the people
who made a scientific progress were usually very, very
wealthy people, or at least people with, with
good enough, uh, monetary resources and other kinds
of resources to devote their time and they didn't have
to answer to anybody but mo for the most part
, uh, and they could dedicate as much time
as they wanted and as long as they wanted to
study any kind of subject like Charles Darwin in the
, in the 19th century. And I guess that
also to some extent, Einstein in the 20th century
. But, uh, I mean, um,
uh, uh, those were on the one hand
, lucky people and on the other hand, uh
, privileged people. And on the other hand,
I mean, if we are to really push science
forward more rapidly and involving more people, which I
imagine it's better than just rely on perhaps a handful
of lucky geniuses or something like that, uh,
I, I mean, it, it's not really
feasible to wait for that kind of thing to happen
. Right. No, I think, you know
, another point which a lot of people have made
and seems right? Also is that when we're thinking
about this desire to have science as a group working
on many, many different types of topics, um
like another way that you get that is by drawing
on different kinds of people with different backgrounds and concerns
. So in some way, like being, you
know, whatever a wealthy gentleman means, you have
all the freedom to work on whatever wacky thing you
want. But it was also the case that historically
in science, especially if we're looking at like Western
science since the scientific revolution. Well, it's like
a lot of wealthy, independent white European and men
, right? And so there's not as much diversity
as a perspective as you would see in a lot
of scientific communities now. And so people also think
, well, that kind of diversity of perspective is
another source for new ideas, different ideas, ideas
that will push science forward. Yeah. Also because
uh I don't know if this is something that you
look into specifically. But over the years I've been
talking on the show with um for example, cultural
psychologists and cognitive scientists and uh even people that come
from different cultural backgrounds tend to think about things in
different ways. And it's very much valuable to science
to have people with different cultural backgrounds and coming to
the table with different uh cognitions, I guess.
Yeah. And I think there's a lot of examples
from the history of science that demonstrate how that can
can be beneficial. Uh So since we're talking about
science, from the perspective of uh game theory or
trying to understand science through game theory or more specifically
evolutionary game theory, uh is the scientific community also
a population that undergoes selection, I think it can
be thought of that way. So there's been this
kind of handful of people using evolutionary models to think
about scientific communities. So the idea of thinking about
science as an evolutionary system goes back like much further
. So for example, David Hall wrote this very
influential book where he was thinking about the evolution of
science, but he was thinking of the units more
or as ideas where the ideas themselves are being selected
and changed. Whereas recently, a bunch of people
have been writing papers where the units are scientists and
you can ask questions like who remains within a scientific
community and why um given that scientists are using different
sorts of approaches, what approaches will tend to stay
in the community, what approaches will tend to spread
, uh which ones will be more prominent and so
will be copied more. And you know, this
isn't, it's not like um this is entirely novel
, you know, there's this whole field of cultural
evolutionary theory which thinks about how do we take evolutionary
theory and apply it to human practices and norms and
actions and beliefs and systems. And so you can
do the same thing within science. It, it
, time I think pretty successfully. Mhm. Bicultural
evolutionary theory, you mean, uh, the work
, uh, been being done by people like Robert
Boyd, Peter Richardson, Joe Eric and perhaps,
uh, more on the side of the Parisian school
than Spur, I mean, people like that.
Yeah, those are a bunch of the, like
, most prominent people doing cultural evolutionary theory though.
There's actually, there's a lot of threads of it
, you know, there's um people who do more
game theoretic approaches, people who do other types of
different sorts of approaches. There's a lot of uh
work in anthropology on cultural evolutionary theory that's less modeling
, more empirical. Um It's a thoroughly interdisciplinary area
. And so you have all these kind of different
paradigms or frameworks for thinking about cultural evolution. Yeah
. I it in fact, integrates a lot of
different things. There are people that work uh with
everything from evolutionary psychology to anthropology, cultural evolution,
human ecology. Basically they apply all of those tools
in cultural evolutionary theory, right? Yeah, that's
right. So uh let me ask you about another
topic regarding science just before we move on to other
subjects. So, um there are scientific retraction sometimes
uh when it happens, does it usually work or
not? Uh So this is I I take it
you're asking this question because I have this paper on
scientific retraction. Um This is a topic that has
been really interesting to me because, you know,
we think of science as this kind of, you
know, we would want science to be an ideal
community of learners, right? And that's what science
is trying to be a group of people who are
using the best methods, the best practices available to
learn about the world and develop good beliefs about the
world. And like science is pretty successful in doing
that. But of course, there are, it's
, it's all it's people in the end. So
it's not gonna be perfect. So one thing that's
been really widely observed in people who do empirical studies
of scientific communities is that retractions often fail or aren't
fully successful. So maybe someone um uh is caught
having committed fraud and some of their papers are retracted
often if you look later at those papers, they're
being cited in the literature and they're not being cited
as retracted or fraudulent papers, they're just being cited
sort of straightforward by people who don't know that they've
actually been retracted. And so this happens kind of
again and again and again. Um and then related
to that, I think you see similar things happening
outside of science just in broader societies. So for
example, during the COVID-19 pandemic, it happened dozens
of times that there would be some uh scientific claim
shared by journalists, you know, for example,
uh there was this very influential early study done in
Northern California that um claimed that the fatality rate of
COVID was much lower than it actually is that study
was really widely cited, uh turned out they had
, had an error in their initial reprint that they
quickly fixed, but their initial numbers propagated pretty far
. And I don't think the like report of the
error and the proper numbers propagated nearly as far.
Right. So people didn't get the message that their
initial numbers were wrong and in fact, underestimated the
fatality. Right. So that's another kind of instance
, they're both instances where you have these scientific claims
that have like viability legitimacy, they spread in social
networks when they are reversed or known to be false
. Not everyone finds out that they would were false
who initially found out about this claim. So some
co-author um Anders Guy and Travis Laquan and I built
models where we would have a network and we would
have something like a false claim spreading in the network
and then we'd introduce a retraction and let that spread
as well. And we would ask, well,
what are the situations where people find out about the
retraction? When do they continue to hold the false
belief, et cetera? Um And we found that
in a lot of cases, people would just hold
the false belief as an accident of history. You
know, you have these things spreading from person to
person. And so some people just get the false
thing and they never hear about the true thing.
It's just what happens randomly, right? Because of
chance. But we found some things like would influence
how often that happened. So for example, we
found that retractions or reversals that are instigated by the
original source are much more successful. So if I'm
hearing the network and I say something false, it
starts to spread. If I say oops, that
was false, that spreads to the same people and
they care about that. But if some other person
is like, no, they're wrong and they're not
sort of connected to the people finding out about this
false thing in the first place. People don't care
as much about this retraction, right? So they're
the right people who hold false beliefs aren't finding out
they're wrong. So that was one thing. Another
thing is that weirdly like very prominent false beliefs were
often more reversible because, you know, imagine,
um some study that turns out to be wrong but
nobody knows about it. Well, someone comes and
says this was wrong. Well, nobody cares.
Right. So there aren't that many people to spread
the retraction. Whereas a very prominent false belief,
if someone shows that it's wrong, there's a lot
of people to spread the retraction to spread that it
was wrong. So we found in our models that
sometimes uh some false belief being really widely held meant
that it was easier to reverse. Mhm. And
I mean, if that happens, um would you
have any suggestions as to how people should deal with
it? I mean, when the paper gets retracted
. If for some reason, there are some people
out there that never get to learn that it was
retracted and keep citing it in their own papers.
What would be perhaps good solutions to try to deal
with that? If we're talking about within science,
there are some things that we recommend that um other
people have talked about too. So one thing is
that authors and journals aren't usually incentivized to talk about
something being retracted because who wants to say like I
was wrong or we published a paper where the person
committed fraud. Uh So especially with journals, a
lot of them are not very active about sharing that
something's been retracted. You know, they're not like
splashing it on their front page. Uh They're often
not even like making a very clear sort of retraction
statement on the page where it might be linked.
Sometimes you'll just see ones where it just says retract
in like a tiny little word. So I think
journals should be much more active about communicating about retraction
. Um Search engines like Google scholar should be much
better about making clear when things are retracted. Like
have a big note on the top of a paper
when you search it saying that it's been retracted.
Um As much as possible individuals when they're being responsible
should share when they were wrong or when they cited
something wrong. But of course, it's hard to
get people to do that uh, the other thing
I think would be good is, you know,
when academic journals publish a paper, um, you
know, there's a whole process of like checking over
that paper, if we have a database of retracted
articles, that would be a natural time step to
just compare all the citations in the paper with things
that have been retracted and flag ones that might be
false as well. Mhm. So, changing topics
now, I mean, I've already had many discussions
on the show with moral philosophers, particularly moral philosophers
about this, but also with uh with uh some
scientists is naturalism congruent with any me ethics. I
mean, if we, if we tackle things from
a naturalistic perspective, I mean, are we committing
ourselves necessarily to, for example, moral realism or
moral anti realism? Um So I, like,
you know, as a grad student, I co
wrote a paper on this with like my advisor.
It's not, it's not really my area of study
. Um I mean, I can tell you what
we said in that, which was something like you
can both have a meta ethics that's thoroughly naturalistic,
you know, things that like human brains evolved the
way they did for all of these sort of practical
and pragmatic reasons that evolution explains why we have the
moral beliefs and instincts we have. So we wanna
say you can hold that true and at the same
time be like, but I have first order moral
beliefs and I still gonna argue for them with all
the sort of force that I did before. Like
, I can believe all that and still think,
like, hurting people is wrong. And so I
can still argue about what we ought to do and
not do whether or not I have a fully naturalistic
picture of human morality. Mhm. Uh, ok
. So another topic that you've, uh, wrote
a bit about is perceptual categories. So, do
we know if they have evolved to track properties of
the world or not? Yeah. So this is
something that, um, gets into a lot of
like really deep discussions and debate in philosophy, philosophy
of perception, but also in cognitive science, I
mean, obviously, so we have our perceptual senses
to mediate our behaviors in the world, right?
Where organisms, our goals, I mean, when
I put goals, our goals as shaped by evolution
are to like eat, drink sleep, keep our
bodies alive, eventually reproduce, right? Um,
and maybe keep our Children alive so that they can
reproduce. So we have bodies that are trying to
do those things. Perception is useful in as much
as it allows us to do those things. Um
, so some people like Don Hoffman have made arguments
like, well, there's no reason to think that
our perception needs to accurately track the world, then
all it needs to do is promote our fitness.
And so it could be the case that it promotes
our fitness in ways that, um, but by
, you know, creating perceptual categories or perceptual experiences
that don't sort of glom onto the stuff that's really
there, the structures that really exist. Uh Now
I think that, and then, and he says
for that reason, we have no reason to think
that our sort of perception and our perceptual experiences is
anything like what the world is like or tells us
about what the world is like. Um so he
uses models to do that. I use similar models
to make a different argument, which is something like
, uh, in fact, there's plenty of reason
to often think that the structure of the world is
really important in determining how our fitness is going to
look like. Um, that there's at least going
to be some reasons why our perception needs to tell
us veridical or world tracking things in order for us
to survive. And so making the jump to,
like, our perception has nothing to do with the
world seems like much too strong of a jump to
me for that reason. Yeah, I, I've
in fact already had, uh, Doctor Hoffman twice
on the show and the, yes, he,
he has at least some compelling arguments to support his
position. But, uh, I mean, since
you come from, uh, I'm not sure if
you would label it the opposite place or at,
but at least a different place. Uh, how
do you look at it exactly? Do you look
at it through a pragmatic lens, for example,
since you're also coming at it from an evolutionary perspective
. Yeah. So um I do think of perception
through this kind of pragmatic lens and like an evolutionary
lens where I assume, you know, there's some
things, some structures in the world, uh there
are actions that would be better or worse for organisms
to take in the presence of these different structures.
So for example, if humans are in the presence
of blackberries eating is a good action. If they're
in the presence of uh juniper berries eating is not
such a good action. Um So there are ways
in which the structure of the world impacts like our
fitness based on how we act. So I use
models that assume that and then, um I ask
in these models, well, what, what will
our perceptual categories look like? And there are certain
kinds of things that will often be the case.
So part of um Dawn's argument is that, for
example, uh you know, there might be things
in the world that are different from each other and
we should respond to them in the same way and
then we can categorize them together. So maybe something
like a lower level animal, say a dragon fly
can have the same perceptual experience for many different types
of food because all they need to do in response
to that food is eat. And so their reception
doesn't have to disambiguate those things um, and he
would say, well then their perception isn't tracking the
world. My response would be something like there's ways
in which it's not tracking the world in ways in
which it is, you know, it is putting
whatever all the, I don't know what Dragonflies eat
, all of that kind of little bug into the
same edible category. Right. And all of this
kind of bug are in the same category. So
it's tracking sameness among those different food sources. It's
failing to track difference between them. But that doesn't
mean there's no sort of important correspondence between perception and
the world. Mhm So uh I would like to
ask you now about learning generalization and evolutionarily stable strategy
. So, and to compare them as models for
learning basically. So uh first of all, tell
us what is learning generalization. Yeah. So this
is a completely like ubiquitous, widespread learning behavior where
um so an organism encounters something in the world,
it learns something about it. So maybe it learns
like touching good eating good, avoiding good, whatever
it learns. Um But that learned response is not
just applied to that single state that the organism encountered
, but to many similar states. So if I
try eating a blackberry and it tastes good, I
don't learn to eat only that exact blackberry with that
exact weight, that exact color, that exact smell
, that exact location I learned to eat blackberries in
general. Um And that sounds like, well,
Yeah, obviously, duh. Right. Of course
, you should do that, but it's actually a
nontrivial task, you know, uh when you expand
out from that first initial stimuli, how many things
do you include, like, how dissimilar, how
similar, what counts as something that you ought to
eat in response to this initial learning experience? Um
So that's what learning generalization is. Uh Do you
want me to talk about like why it's interesting from
the perspective of like, OK, so there's this
classic argument in evolutionary game theory. So the study
of the evolution of strategic behaviors uh having to do
with learning. So when you have these strategic situations
, there are certain kinds of behaviors that are um
are going to be the ones you expect to evolve
. Basically, the ones that can be stable in
an evolutionary scenario. And the argument is something like
this, you should only expect the selection of learning
that will learn those ideal strategies. Because if you
have a learner who doesn't learn those ideal strategies,
then they're gonna get a lower payoff than the ones
who do, then they should be selected against.
So expect organisms to learn these stable strategies in these
strategic scenarios. But, and you know, I've
done work arguing this other people have as well.
But the issue with that argument is that there are
tradeoffs and benefits in learning. So learning doesn't happen
all in one second. It takes time and you're
getting payoffs over the entire time that that's happening.
So learning generalization is a behavior that doesn't lead to
these ideal evolutionarily stable strategies. These perfect strategies basically
because it leads you to extend learning to situations where
you didn't uh experience the um the first learning experience
, right to new situations. And so you extend
your learning to situations where it might not be quite
as good as the ones where you learned it.
So I use models to show that this is the
case learning generalization isn't going to fit with this kind
of classic argument about learning, but very clearly,
it has evolved. And the reason is that it
helps you learn faster. So imagine if you had
to learn the right behavior in response to every single
blackberry you ever saw individually. Well, you're not
learning, you're not really learning at all, but
in any case, you're learning very, very,
very slowly. And so you're gonna have all these
times in your lifetime where you could have extended a
lesson to a useful scenario, but you didn't.
And so the idea is that selection is going to
account for that need for speed, even if this
kind of speedy learning behavior necessarily stops you from learning
kind of most perfect precise thing you could. Mhm
But does that mean then that learning generalization uh contradicts
evolutionarily stable strategies as a model for learning or does
it implement in any way? Well, so OK
, so evolutionarily stable strategies, they are um outcomes
in a game that you expect to evolve. So
that's a little bit separate from learning. It's not
the case that in fact, they always evolve even
in evolutionary models, but that's a whole separate thing
. Um So they're the sort of behaviors you expect
to evolve. But you can also ask what learning
behaviors get selected for. And so the argument is
about, will you see learning behaviors that always lead
to those evolutionarily stable strategies or will you see other
learning behaviors? And you know, the argument is
you'll see other learning behaviors because they're faster or have
other kinds of benefits besides getting to the perfect strategies
? Mhm So uh the last topic I would like
to get into today is misinformation during and about the
COVID-19 pandemic. So, uh first of all,
what do you think uh what were the questions that
you found more interesting uh about this topic from coming
from the perspective of the perspective of game theory?
Um Well, so I thought so not just coming
from the perspective of game theory. So a lot
of my work on um misinformation that isn't in game
theory but in other kinds of modeling. Uh But
so there were a lot of things that happened during
the pandemic that were like really interesting from the point
of view of thinking about misinformation, spread of beliefs
, social spread of beliefs, all this stuff.
So here was one thing. Um So Jim Weall
and I published this book in 2019, the misinformation
Age where one of the things we argued is that
in cases where false beliefs really hurt people, they
should be less likely to hold those false beliefs.
So for example, if everyone is like, oh
Red Kool Aid is the most delicious. It's even
if that were somehow not true, uh It's totally
fine for me to conform with everyone and drink Red
Kool Aid or to trust everyone in saying, say
they said it was nutritious to trust everyone and saying
it was nutritious. It doesn't matter. It's not
gonna hurt me if I drink Red Kool Aid,
right? It's just not that bad for me,
even if this belief was a little wrong. On
the other hand, if everyone was like, oh
it's safest to drink cyanide, we shouldn't see that
false belief spreading, right? We shouldn't see everyone
starting to drink that because it really matters to people
. If they get it wrong. Now with COVID
, I would have thought before the pandemic that this
would be a scenario. That's more like the latter
case because you could make choices during the pandemic where
if you make that choice today, it directly leads
to your death in 24 days, right? You
just die in a couple weeks and in particular exposure
, choices could put people at risk of death just
very directly and there's a pretty high fatality rate from
COVID, but you still saw all of these kinds
of social effects on belief and misinformation related to COVID
. In spite of its very prominent, like visible
real world danger to people, you still saw people
choosing to be exposed based on partisan identity, for
example, um or choosing whether or not to wear
masks based on their social identities or whether they were
conforming with other people in their social networks. Uh
So I thought that that was very interesting and surprised
me quite a lot actually. And, uh I
mean, how do you make sense of it then
? I mean, I guess the way I make
sense of it is thinking that like, you know
, social pressures are just stronger and more important to
people than maybe I initially would have thought. And
they're just, you know, a whole thesis of
this book was that like, social stuff matters to
belief a lot. And I feel like, oh
, I, I guess that was right, even
more right than I expected, you know, um
, that people would be influenced by these sort of
social factors so much that they would be willing to
take fairly significant risks to their home. But,
I mean, from the perspective, you've, you've
used to tackle this topic, uh do these beliefs
that are epistemic wrong, I guess, uh still
serve uh particular functions, namely social function functions.
And is that the main reason why they spread,
even though they might be harmful to people who believe
them and spread them Yeah, that's right. They
often can. So um this is something that I
haven't exactly model but, you know, I've looked
at other people's work on one thing that beliefs do
is play roles as far as in group out group
signaling, communicating your social identity, bonding with other
people, impressing other people. So holding beliefs and
sharing beliefs and taking actions based on belief, it
all has functions, you know, with respect to
like our bodies and their relation to the world,
but it also has functions with respect to us and
our social relationships. So for example, I might
put on a mega hat to signal to the people
. I want to signal to I'm part of your
in group and they will assume in my wearing that
hat that I also hold various sorts of beliefs about
the world and how it works. So do you
think that if we uh get a good understanding of
how all of these works? I mean, why
people hold certain beliefs and why they communicate them to
other people that perhaps we could, could use this
knowledge to tackle misinformation? I certainly think it can
help. Um So for example, understanding online platforms
and how the spread of belief works on online platforms
, I think can help those platforms develop better information
environments or better algorithms to protect people. So just
to give a little example, again, not my
research, other people's research, but um it seems
like emotional language has a big impact on how wide
widely spread things like tweets on Twitter are. Uh
And so knowing that can help a platform realize,
OK, if you have emotional language attached to say
misinformation, um maybe that's the sort of thing the
algorithm shouldn't actively promote. And so that's an example
of knowing something about how humans work, possibly helping
to improve information spread in a social group. Mhm
. Yeah. And perhaps, I guess that holding
certain very influential people accountable for what they say,
like for example, Donald Trump would also help a
little bit. Yeah. Ok. Yeah. Uh
ok. So Doctor o'connor, uh just before we
go, would you like to tell people where they
can find you and your work on the internet there
? I have a website. It's just my name
Kelly o'connor dot com. I put up all my
preprinted papers there. So any research that I've done
can be found there except my books. Um and
I'm also on Twitter. It's Ken Meister is my
handle like my name and then Meist er my dad
used to call me the Ken Meister and then when
I became, you know, when I actually got
a master's degree, like I thought it would be
funny. Yeah, it totally makes sense. Ok
, so uh I'm leaving links to that in the
description box of the interview and Doctor o'connor, thank
you so much again for taking the time to come
on the show. It's been really fun to talk
to you. Yeah, nice talking to you,
Ricardo and hopefully we'll catch each other around sometime.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview.
Until the end. If you liked it, please
do not forget to like it, share, comment
and subscribe. And if you like more generally,
what I'm doing, please consider support the show on
Patreon or paypal. You have all of the links
in the description of this interview. This show is
brought to you by En Lights learning and development.
Done differently. Check their website at alights.com. I
would also like to give a huge thank you to
my main patrons and paypal supporters per Larson, Jerry
Mueller and Frederick Sunda Bernards O of Election and Visor
Adam Castle Matthew Whit Whitting Bear, no wolf,
Tim Hollis, Eric Alania, John Connors Philip Forrest
Connelly, Robert Winde Nai Z Mark Nevs Colin Holbrook
, Simon Columbus, Phil Kor Michael Stormer, Samuel
Andreev for the S Alexander Dan Bauer Fergal Ken Hall
, her og Michel Jonathan lebron Jars and the Samuel
K, Eric Heins Mark Smith Jan We Amal S
Franz David Sloan Wilson, Yasa, Des Roma Roach
Diego, Jannik Punter, Da Man Charlotte Bliss,
Nicole Barbar Wam and Pao Assy Naw Guy Madison,
Gary GH, some of the Adrian Yin Nick Golden
Paul talent in Ju Bar was Julian Price Edward Hall
, Eden Bronner, Douglas Fry Franca Bertolotti, Gabriel
Pan Cortez, Lelis Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy
, Sonny Smith, John Wiesman, Martin Aland,
Daniel Friedman. William Buckner, Paul George Arnold Luke
Lo A Georges the often Chris Williamson, Peter Oren
, David Williams the Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray,
Alex Shaw and Murray Martinez Chevalier, Bangalore atheists,
Larry Daley Junior Holt Eric B. Starry Michael Bailey
, then Sperber, Robert Grassy Rough the RP MD
, Ior Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radix,
Mark Campbell, Richard Bowen Thomas, the Dubner,
Luke Ni and Greece story, Manuel Oliveira, Kimberly
Johnson and Benjamin Gilbert. A special thanks to my
producers is our web gem Frank Luca Stefi, Tom
Weam Bernard ni Ortiz Dixon, Benedict Mueller Vege,
Gli Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John
Carlo Montenegro, Robert Lewis and Al Nick Ortiz.
And to my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Si
Adrian and Bogdan Kut. Thank you for all.